so you're pretty public with your lady
Fit Mommy who's by the way a great hang
definitely I love her though she's she's
amazing shout out to you Destiny shout
out to Destiny aka the Fit Mommy uh she
said she's gonna legally change her name
to fit Mommy I was like [ __ ] you crazy
as [ __ ] [ __ ] what the [ __ ] I'm about to
be walking around calling you fit hey
fit I barely found out I barely found
out her name was Destiny like six months
ago right I'll be like just use your
[ __ ] name Destiny Fox you use your
names
um but what because you've obviously
been in many situationships since I've
known you what is it about this one that
you make that makes you so happy yeah
I'll be in me climbing business Kev but
that's what I mean that's what I mean I
mean I mean that's why I said
situationships
um I don't know man we just you know we
got a good Bond you know and that's
that's first and foremost you got to
[ __ ] with somebody to accept you for you
you know what I mean and know that you
like grills know that you you know
you know like to do what you do and you
know have fun and you know and and with
the same you know you got to accept all
of their things and I think that it's
acceptance that you know make the bomb
with me and her go so strong you know
what I'm saying that's fair it's love
you know I mean like we ain't never
we never you know of course you know
people argue
get on my [ __ ] nerves I get on her
nerves but uh you know
you get that family bond you know that's
that's kind of tough to break you know
what I'm saying yeah no I just saw you
guys were you like we're hanging out
with your pops and the kids were there
yeah he's hanging out with our Pops kids
we all like family you know what I'm
saying we was just in New York me and my
baby mom shout out to Risa you know what
I'm saying like we was all you know
chilling do the baby mamas get along
uh my baby mama my girlfriend get along
so okay that's cool you know what I'm
saying I mean everybody's cordial if
they see each other you know what I'm
saying they say hi and [ __ ] you know
what I mean they might text me some
stupid [ __ ] right they don't be like
texting each other like you know it
don't be no [ __ ] like that everybody be
pretty much smooth for the reason I get
the [ __ ] you get it I get with all
the [ __ ] yeah they see each other they'd
be like hey hey everything's quarter and
I get that [ __ ] that's what that falls
into play but I'm a man dog I'm a king
you know and part of that is you know
managing all of these personalities and
yeah doing that you know we've been
doing this since the beginning of time
in Africa my [ __ ] you know it ain't no
big deal you know what I'm saying it is
what it is